about right
all right well that's i guess it's not
terrible but we're in the 80s and we've
got near 50 humidity so we're
humidity is foreign to us that's just
not what we have usually in the desert
except this time of year when it's
monsoon season the sun is up the
humidity is high the dew points are high
it's just telling us there's a lot of
moisture out there but at least we're
going to have good sunshine today and of
course the humidity will drop a little
bit as that sun kind of burns off the
moisture out there 82 on the strip 79 in
summerlin and 78 at mountains edge 81 at
sunrise manor and
we've got 82 right now in henderson 75
out at red rock roll in the future cast
it looks like that we could be seeing
some cells popping up this afternoon and
the chance for thunderstorms is in the
mountains today and it looks like the
higher elevations could get some of
those storms gusty winds lightning maybe
some isolated downpours today so that's
what we're going to be looking for as we
look at the national outlook i talked
about those hot spots look at the heat
watches all the way through the
mid-south ohio valley heat warnings and
parts of the east coast and definitely
heat warnings again across the pacific
northwest so our high pressure
delivering those temperatures a little
above normal for us but the monsoon
moisture continues to circulate and with
the lift and the moisture in place and
the daytime heating the mountains will
be ripe for thunderstorms about a 40
percent chance today so please be
careful if you're going to do hiking get
it done early today if you can don't be
caught up there in those thunderstorms
105 for the valley should see a lot of
sunshine and heat today tomorrow 107
mostly sunny into the weekend with
temperatures around 106. the chance for
monsoon storms returns next week as of
tuesday wednesday thursday boy temps
will be down but the monsoon moisture
back up